ladies and gentlemen uh tonight is a
very big deal check this out it's my
sixth to last show on my fourth to last
network
what a career never a bump in the road
anyway
we're a nomadic people we roam we're
hunter gatherers are we not yeah
very hot today it's hundred and five in
los angeles right now
setting records yeah the uh cdc
authorized me to tell you guys
while in the theater tonight the masks
have to stay on
but the clothes can come off
don't no no don't
don't for a second no no don't for a
second act like that would be an erotic
treat okay
yeah and also you people do not want
skin touching those seats yeah
hey our last nightly show is next
thursday june 24th
uh and people are asking me people are
asking me uh
what's next and i just wanted to tell
you all tonight my plan is to wrap up
this show
then start my new career posing as conan
o'brien on hollywood boulevard
and yeah
i'll have i'll have
i'll have a fanny pack
uh i'll be the guy between the fat
spiderman and the fatter spiderman so
look out for me because i need the work
anyway
you know one thing we're doing these
last two weeks is we're taking a look at
some of
our favorite moments from our time here
at tbs uh
tonight i wanted to show you some of my
favorite
cold opens the start of the shows that
we would do
from our trips down to comic-con over
the past couple of years
i have to tell you yeah it was
when we started at tbs we tried so many
new things we didn't know what would
happen
comic-con was something we tried and it
was such a discovery such a
magical discovery some of our favorite
shows happened down at comic con
the first cold opening uh is one that we
did
from comic con 2015 and at the time
mad max fury road was the movie of the
year
anyway here's how we started that show
check it out
oh hey andy hey conan i'm heading down
to san diego to comic-con now are you
ready
sure you gonna take the train no you
know it's only a little over two hours
so i thought i'd drive you know listen
to some tunes on the way down
driving sounds fun can i take along of
course
are you ready now yeah let's go to
comic-con let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i don't know where we got lost i still
can't see it i'm coming down
see we passed san clemente yeah we're
off to five we passed saint clemente but
we're not on that we should have hitler
we should have hit la jolla by now you
know well the thing is is the guitar's
so loud i can't hear the gps i'm sorry
it's so much fun i get carried away i
know i know but it's okay hit me up
before we go oh
here we go here we go
[Music]
all right this next opening from a comic
con is from comic con 2016 and at the
time
batman v superman batman vs superman was
the big movie
at comic-con so here's how he started
that week's shows
i don't know i mean it was okay but it
seems like every single
superhero movie these days is just an
excuse for the good guys to fight each
other
oh i know it's like they think up the
lamest excuse for them to be mad at each
other
just so they can stage a big fight scene
at the end i mean i still liked it i'd
give it three stars i'd give it 3.5
well you mean three and a half yeah i
the same thing 3.5 three and a half it's
not the same thing
no one uses decimal points when they
rate a movie it's just
stupid i used my points to rate a movie
you know there were times and this is
one of them when i just want to smash
you
but why don't you try it right here
right now oh yeah
it is one
you just started a war i'm gonna enjoy
taking you down wait
wasn't it just daytime and sunny
if we're gonna fight it has to be in the
rain
at night and why are we fighting again
it doesn't matter people pay billions of
dollars to see this [ __ ]
[Applause]
hey andy do you
bleed
[Applause]
tell the devil conan accenture
uh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
damn it
you